hot breath this can tie into our first
question here from trainer steve
because it's about your skill as a
comedian he asks
when did john first notice his comedic
skill level jump
when did he see his largest spurts and
growth and to what does he attribute
those jumps
um one day growth
i think it was like weird moments like
when i was just started
you know back in my day i'm gonna sound
super old here you
emceed and then and then when you got
really good as an mc
you were a feature and then when you're
really good as a feature
you you got to be a headliner right and
then but emceeing was a skill
like emceeing was i mean
it was a skill kind of a lot of people
don't have now like their hosts but
all they're thinking is my podcast is
pretty good i don't know why i'm not
featuring
like they don't know how to hope like do
not believe how many times i'm at clubs
and you go can you just
can you just plug this for me or can you
just and they just
they're horrible at announcements and
they're saying and you say something
they're like well
i don't normally empty okay but you took
the job so don't be a shitty emcee
like it's a whole so somewhere during
that when i was that young
like there was a part where i was like
i'm a really good emcee
this is a thing i'm gonna i'm gonna
learn my my minute of welcome to the
club
the waitresses are gonna add a whole
used cars men's
you know uh thing i would do in the
first minute on stage
and then i would do a little break take
the mic out now i'm not
mc guy non-comic guy and i would do the
thing and then i put and bring up the
feature
so there are parts there where i i
started knowing i'm i'm
stronger than a lot of these features
that i'm working with
you know even when i was a young guy at
and then um then i had a college growth
spurt you know because i was doing maybe
colleges a year this is way back in in
naka you know era because i was 20
something you know i
was hey what's with roommates and ramen
noodles and blah blah blah
right um so there was that and then
um you know i think maybe
after my first special i kind of felt oh
i have this dialed in
you know and where with my career i felt
like i have some years
you know that i'm like man everything is
as tight as
this is this is bulletproof i could walk
up and trying to
like this is bulletproof and then you
have other years or when you rearrange
stuff or you
do an album and here you're just like
yeah
this is this is mediocre i'm it's not
you know i'm hitting the rim a lot
and you know that's still something i
don't think you ever can kind of figure
out
yeah that was even like uh when we had
we did one of these with nate bargatzi
and he's like at the end of every
special
he immediately reverts back to i have no
material i'll never be able to write
another joke again what have i done
like there's this self-doubt i feel like
maybe a lot of comics have of like how
could i ever do that again
oh yeah and especially right now um
two new albums i put out an album in
november
um or december i forgot and then even
with this whole thing going on
uh i'm going to one of those phases
where i'm like i don't know what
material
i'm going to talk about once we start
performing again because in my head
already it's like
people in front of me talking about
tiger king and
no toilet paper do you know what i mean
like exactly
because every comic right so i could do
my experience in stories would be
different than yours just because
we're different people but now you have
everybody going through
the same exact thing right so it's
so you're going to have a lot of here's
some zoom material
that that's going to be there so that's
already in my head going i'm not even
going to waste my time
talking about that because a year from
now on netflix
there's gonna be seven specials and i
can tell you the set list
of those seven specials you know yeah
i'm gonna be
zoom tiger king i got pregnant during
the thing what'd you guys do in court
like there's all this it's gonna happen
look you know look how many videos there
are comics making food right now
it's it's going to be a thing so i kind
of get like locked in my head a little
i'm like yeah i don't think i have
anything anything to talk about
forever yeah but then it always comes
back
exactly nate says that after every
every special then cranks out another
hilarious one so
yeah that's just the insecure comic in
all of us yeah